hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the 1954
uh ussr junior championship that was
held in leningrad
uh it's a game between mikhail and boris
posky so both of them future world
champions and this game comes as a
suggestion from
farhad torshabi he said that i've never
shown the game
between tal and spassky and i thought
out of all the games that i've shown and
i've
shown like over 2 000 of them uh it'd be
pretty impossible if i've never shown a
game between talon and spasky and then i
went to check my videos and uh what do
you know i've never made a video
uh where tall faces paski i mean who
knew
and uh i decided to show you uh the
first game they ever played maybe it's
not the first game gave or played it's
the first official game
in an official tournament that they ever
played maybe they played a friendly
blitz game but
i don't know uh so it's a it's a very
nice game i'm sure you're gonna enjoy it
and if you enjoy
uh seeing videos of first encounters i
will also include
uh the first and second link in the
description below will be uh bobby
fischer's first encounter with mikhail
botvinik
uh and also i will include uh mikhail
thal's first encounter with
vishwanathan anand so i hope you guys
enjoyed that as those are both
really really great games do check it
out if you have the time as well
so like i said uh tal being 18 years old
here spasky being 19
for those of you who may not know this
esposkie is still
alive and well he's 84 years old back in
russia and as far as i know he is still
in very good health
and uh a few few photos emerge of him uh
from time to time uh so just in case you
you didn't know this
uh and both of them like for example
bobby fischer bobby fisher
got his grandmaster title by uh
qualifying for the 1959 candidates
tournament and they couldn't have like
just anyone playing the candidates
tournament so they gave him the grand
master title
uh tal got his grandmaster title he uh
won the soviet
championship i think in 1957 and boris
posky uh got his grandmaster title by
qualifying for the candidates tournament
of 1956.
so uh as you can see they were all of
them were ahead of their time and
they were playing much much stronger
than their rating would suggest
but that being said let's check out the
game as like i said
it's quite a nice one so tal has the
white pieces and he opens
with c4 so tal goes for the english
opening and spasky goes for
knight to f6 so let's see what happens
here first
ever game between spasky and tal uh
knight to c3
uh with e6 by spawsky d4 and now uh
striking uh towards the center with c5
going for that d4
pawn we have d5 advancing the pawn uh
basically transposing into the benoni
defense e capture c
captures and now g6 and here uh well
e4 is uh very often played move even in
those days and
nowadays as well uh spassky goes for
knight as a tall goes for knight to f3
he
still waits for the uh for the e4 pawn
because uh
the this one this is a game from 1954 uh
and
tal was already known as a pretty pretty
vicious benoni player and here
uh spassky employing the bononi defense
against tal himself uh
meant that spassky was trying to kind of
mess with his head a little bit
but also uh just to show him who's boss
and
uh probably tal tried to
adjust to this by maybe playing some
offbeat ideas in the opening so here we
have bishop to g7
and now bishop to f4 yeah it seems like
a normal developing move but it actually
comes with a trick if spassky just
castles here bishop to d6
attacks the rook and the c5 pawn so
spassky can
do it just yet spasky plays d6 here and
now
uh h3 not allowing a normal developing
mover like for example bishop to g4
uh we have castles and now e3 uh by
nisha and here tal doesn't uh advance
the pawn all the way to e4 even though
it's a perfectly fine square for the
pawn so he he's trying to play a bit of
a different game
so here we have knight to e8 uh later on
uh
this knight is gonna uh is gonna come to
d6 as you'll see but now
uh you are making room for this pawn to
come to f5 and you're also freeing up
the dark square bishop to be a very
powerful piece so here uh
bishop to e2 knights to d7 now the
knight can come to e5
and here we have castles and now uh
there is one game
in the database that reached this exact
same position but after knight to e5
uh it is as of move 11 that this
position has never been repeated again
since this game of the uh lending the
junior championship of 1954.
uh here we have bishop captures on e5
that's a very strong knight so here
misha eliminates it we have d
captures on e5 and now knight to d2
so here tal already has a past the
d-pawn
which is uh which is incredible as it's
only moved 13 but spassky
says no problem that's just going to
give me a beautiful outpost for my
knight on d6
and i'm going to be blockading your pawn
without much trouble so here f5
and now queen the b3 already uh the
queen is on a very nice square
ideas like d6 are coming so uh you you
have to be careful of some future
discoveries here
so knight the d6 from spawsky and now
knight to c4
so it's a great square for the knight uh
and now
e4 spassky also grabs some space in the
center
they're controlling the d3 the f3
squares now the bishop
really comes alive uh and here uh tal
goes
knight to b5 an interesting approach
here might be something like just
captures queen captures and knight b5
then because then you can start pushing
your d-pawn right away but
black shouldn't really be in all that
much trouble for example d6
check it doesn't really do all that much
king h8
you're going to play knight c7 attack
the rook here and after
this guy moves you're gonna defend the
pawn with rook to d1
but in the long run this pawn might uh
might really just be a weakness
so tal decides against this star decides
to go knight to b5 right away
now it's possibly who captures on b5
captures captures and then now
b6 just defending the pawn here
we have d6 by tal advancing his past
pawn and
now bishop to d7 pushing the queen back
queen to b3
and now uh the incredible b5
uh spawsky doesn't care about any
discoveries because wherever the knight
goes to and delivers the discovery
we all know what's what follows and that
is of course c4
and here uh tal does uh tell did what he
did best uh he just decided uh all right
so obviously i have to sacrifice
something we're gonna sacrifice a piece
uh but it's not really gonna be an
actual sacrifice since he's going to get
a lot of material back so here we have
knight the b6 check a nice discovery
from the queen
uh also connecting with the rook so
black's only move here
is c4 this is what possibly goes for
the ship captures on c for another check
with b
captures and now queen captures on c4
again
with check so uh you could move the king
but spassky prefers rook to f7
just blocking check and keeping the rook
on the seventh rank
uh we have knight captures queen
captures and now as the b two pawn is
under attack just queen to b3
tal defends it and now says all right
the position is
uh uh is pretty good for both white and
black
i have two rooks but you have a rook and
the bishop pair so
black should be preferred but white does
have this incredible pass pawn and d6 so
it's a
it's a tricky position uh something that
we all know
tall thrives in but in his younger days
possibly was also a pretty pretty uh
crazy player himself so i don't think he
minded this at all so here he played
bishop to e5 going after this d6 pawn
and now rook ate the c1 thal says all
right
have the pawn be my guest uh and then
i'm gonna play rook after d1 and what
are you going to do then
so here capturing the pawn now with the
uh
with the you know overseeing eye of the
engines we know that
just capturing the pawn doesn't really
hurt black's position
because if b bishop captures on d6 and
rook after d1 well with styles idea
you can simply defend it with queen to
f8 this is the only good move for black
and now
point is after let's say we defend the
bishop once again you can move it and
now the rook from f7 guards the bishop
on
on d7 that's why the rook to f7 was a
better move than king to h8 in that
position
so after rook 8 to c1 we have king to g7
as possibly refrains from capturing the
the pawn just yet you can see that
uh tal's mind tricks were already fully
operational
at the age of 18. uh so came to g7 and
now rook after d1
that i'll just defends his past pawn we
have a5 by spassky and now
rook to c7 so now the light square
bishop cannot move as
a queen captures on f7 would happen here
we have queen to e8 and now
uh queen to d5 so again what do you play
here uh
spasky does have the bishop pair but
it's very very hard to
get it to be even at all operational let
alone fully operational so here
simply a4 and now tal finds a brilliant
move
and that is b4 uh not uh really a
no-brainer
uh the pawn here should capture up a
song
uh otherwise you're just gonna start
pushing that pawn and promote it so here
a captures on b3 alpha song
uh we have a captures on b3 and here
uh sparsky played bishop back to f6 and
now this means trouble because here
there is one move for tal that
wins the game and it's uh it's quite a
beautiful move
uh it's uh the the greatest move you can
ever play
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this idea with white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on knowing that
the greatest move you can ever play is
always pawn to b4
so for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's b4
and b4 does seem like a reasonable thing
to do because it doesn't seem like you
can imp
improve your position any further i mean
uh
the queen doesn't really have any useful
moves maybe queen to c5
uh can be used to maybe defend the b6
square later on and then you would
pretty much have all of the squares
covered but other than that
uh there's really no good move other
than b4 so b4
is the move you should play here point
is that black's only reasonable defense
is queen to e5
which now falls short to b5 and now the
problem is uh if you just go for example
bishop captures and b5 then uh queen
captures an f7 and you're getting
checkmated king h8 and queen captures an
h7 is checkmate
so you will not be able to capture with
the bishop and you really don't want to
capture with the queen because then the
rook captures and it defends your pawn
then you just continue pushing the pawn
what you would have to do is something
like queen b2 to guard the b6 square
but then we just play queen to c5 hence
queen to c5 and
maybe the start of this whole variation
guarded the b6 square up front and now
black really doesn't have anything
better than queen captures and b5 queen
captures and now
uh if you play uh well bishop captures
on b5 and now uh
you don't play d7 even though it's
something you want to play because black
can simply block with bishop to d3
and now you're never promoting this pawn
because if you move the rook from the
seventh rank the d7 pawn falls
and if you try and push it the bishop of
course covers the d8 square so this
will not uh this will not do however
there is the rook the b1 move you attack
the light square bishop and
wherever the bishop moves doesn't really
matter or if the rooks get traded off
for example captures and captures
now you move the bishop and now we
simply play rook to v8 and that's it
white wins the game uh for example king
f7 we're gonna bring a queen into the
game
captures captures and now you get this
position uh four points each a rook
against the bishop
with perfect play white will win this so
this is uh in the position uh here if
tau plays b4 but for some reason tal
doesn't play b4
tau plays rook to b7 here and rook to b7
is such a
funky move i mean uh it you you would
really have to get into tal's head
to understand rook to b7 if any of you
guys have an idea
why top play rook to b7 here uh i mean
it's uh
it's it's basically the only square
where you don't want your rook to be i
mean
you want this pawn to be able to be
promoted
so rook the b7 uh
i don't know uh it uh it really is a
weird move
uh so i i really don't know
what uh what the idea behind it is like
i said if you guys can help out to do
show in the description
in the comments uh but uh uh you cannot
write in the description that that is
something only i can do
so here uh black played queen to e5
which is the defense we discussed if b4
was played but now b4 simply doesn't
work because now we just trade captures
captures and now bishop to c6 it's like
basically tal played this voluntarily to
not be able to play it
rook captures on f7 king capture and now
our rook is under attack we move it
now king e6 sufficiently defending the
d7 square
this is defended and you will not be
winning this game if anything black is
better here
uh the bishop player will will always
overcome a single rook
so here after and not always but most of
the time so here queen to e5 and now tal
avoids the queen trade with queen to c4
so i'm still guessing there's some
reason top with the rook on b7 but it's
just
very hard to spot it i i guess you could
argue that it defends the b6 square so
you could push it all the way to b6
uh but i don't know maybe it's uh
it's a very silly thing that i'm missing
or maybe it's some sort of a deep
idea that doesn't work and tal maybe
thought it works
uh who knows but okay now uh spasky said
all right you've missed your chance now
it's my turn and now spasky strikes with
f4 we have e captures on f4 queen
captures on f4 and now g3
but this is now already very very
dangerous queen to f3 by spassky
and now you can see that okay spawsky
cannot move the light square bishop
because then uh
tal just wins but also uh if this dark
square bishop moves then spawsky wins
there's this weakness of the f2 pawn and
here
uh tal kind of disregarded that he
played queen to d5
and now uh it's spawski's turn to
shine so feel free to pause the video
here and
win the game for spassky in the quickest
way possible while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on playing
the move spasky played which is bishop
to c3
weird stuff i know and especially to
those of you who found the move spassky
didn't play but it's
much shorter and wins the game much
quicker and that is bishop to e6
it's a brilliant move attacks the queen
and the white rook here
right away uh at the same time so here
you don't really have a better move
than rook captures on f7 with check
bishop captures your queen is still
under attack
and you don't really have uh well you
don't really have a good square for the
queen
the rook is defended by the queen if you
move it the black wing will just gobble
it up
you can't go here you can't go here only
move is queen to d2
and that's exactly where we want the
white queen because now e3 just wins the
game
you'd have to capture it then comes
queen captures and g3 with check then
you're gonna capture the h
upon the e pawn and then the bishops are
just gonna
completely you know join the party and
the white
white will lose this terribly so this
was in the position however spasky went
for bishop to c3 he had a different idea
which is also very cool and now the f2
point is under attacks possible defended
it
and now comes king the h6 a very very
sneaky idea
preparing something very very devious uh
tal played queen to d1
he offered a queen trade but now just
queen to f6 defending this and also
keeping around the bishop you have to be
careful queen to c1 check
could lose you the dark square bishop
and you don't want that to happen so
here
tal went queen to e2 but now comes
bishop to d4
with a triple attack on the f2 pawn here
and also
just e3 is going to be very unpleasant
when it comes and
there's really nothing you can do about
it
so here rook the b4 was played uh but it
doesn't really matter just e3 and there
is really not
much more uh white can do here uh
thoughts best hope is to just
capture the bishop here and then go for
something queen captures
uh trade queens captures captures and
then for example captures captures and
bishop captures an h3
so you might try playing this but the
bishop just stops the pawn controls the
b5 square
so you don't really have a chance of
advancing this pawn and the king will
very easily
join the action it's not not even close
for white to hold
so instead after e3 we have queen to d3
by tal
but now uh well you could play something
uh
well just plain like e captures on f2 uh
that's not what spas he did spasky of
course went for the move from the
thumbnail
he played queen captures an f2 with
check and this is just
uh just fireworks uh he captures an f2
uh was much more precise but queen
captures and f2 is also sufficient uh
it takes perfect play for uh for white
to just to
keep surviving uh but okay uh here tell
of course captured
we have e captures an f2 with check and
now you have to step it back if you keep
guarding the f uh one square with with
both the queen and the king
uh we just bring a queen into the game
with check queen captures and now bishop
to c6 check
and finally spassky's bishop pair is now
fully operational
king h2 we're gonna play rook captures
on f1 and after white gobbles up the
bishop we're gonna deliver rook to h1
checkmate
so this is how uh this uh whole thing
can turn out if uh tal just plays a
silly move like
king to g2 so tao played king the h2
but it doesn't help him because now
again spawsky can bring a queen into the
game he can bring a rook into the game
he can bring whatever but he brings a
knight into the game and this delivers
the uh this move with check and again
if you don't capture the knight if you
play something like king to g2
then bishop the c6 check and now there
are no moves you have to block
queen f3 we're just going to capture it
with the rook
rook captures on d4 and now this
incredible
knight the e3 check king h2 rook f2
king g1 and now rook to f1 check
king to h2 and now as the bishop again
covers the h1 square
rook to h1 with checkmate so really
incredible stuff
so after this uh upon the f1 night
check uh tal decided all right so
there's really nothing to be done here i
have to give the queen back
so rook captures on f1 now again with
threats of bishop c6 and rook to h1
checkmate
uh there's uh not much to be done but if
you don't capture the dark square bishop
you're just
down two pieces and that's i mean you
can't play that
so here tell captured on d4 and now uh
we have first
rook to f2 with check uh you can't just
go bishop to c6 right away because then
g4 and then
okay white creates an escape square here
uh but
rook the f2 check is is also very deadly
king the g1 was played
and here tal just played rook uh spatsky
just played rook to f3
uh and it was in this position on move
45 that uh mikaltal resigned the game
and
the first game ever played between
esposkie and tal uh goes
uh to boris posky uh for this incredibly
incredible victory with
the black pieces so the g pawn is
attacked uh the b pawn is attacked and
there's really nothing for you to do
if you defend here you lose this pawn
and then okay you have a pawn for a
bishop not really something you can play
and if you try defending this spawn by
either defending it with rook or pushing
it it doesn't really matter
we're just going to play uh rook
captures with check and then
even if you defend the bishop guards the
h3 square we're gonna pick up this one
with check as well
so yeah after rook to f3 uh tall
resigned and
spawsky won this brilliant brilliant
victory and what does it all come down
to
it all comes down to this position where
tal failed to play
b4 uh as soon as uh opportunity was
presented or if you miss your chance to
play b4
uh in this uh you know opening or in
many other openings
you might also miss your chance to win
the game
uh so that was the first ever encounter
official encounter between mikhail
italia and boris pasque i hope you guys
enjoyed that
like i said if you enjoy first
encounters uh do check out the bobby
fischer versus
uh botwinic really an outstanding game
i think i really covered that one well
even though it's a two-year-old video
and also check out uh anand versus uh
tal here also a very very nice video
yeah first two links in the
description below uh so yeah once again
hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank austin del rio
justin brockhouse frederick rusek akram
the pilot and kd nuggets for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
if you have a first encounter uh that
you would enjoy seeing
do comment in the comment section below
see you soon